[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a chinese fantasy film called
how long will i love you spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
is a 30 year old woman living in
shanghai she was 12 when her millionaire
father passed away in an accident and
she had to move away from her childhood
home ever since goose started to work
she has been trying to earn enough money
to buy the house back however her lousy
job doesn't pay her well then we are
introduced to liu ming a down on his
luck property designer he is desperately
looking for a client to invest in his
ideas but hasn't met with any success
yet by the end of the day both ming and
gu return home to their shabby
neighborhood strangely enough they seem
to live in the same apartment in the
same building goo puts her clothes in
the laundry while ming cooks himself
dinner after that ming starts to wash
vegetables in the sink and it somehow
ends up in goo's bathtub similarly a
loofah from her tub is inside ming's
sink strangely enough her clothes have
landed inside his cooking pot and his
dinner is where goo's clothes are
supposed to be throughout the night
their belongings somehow continue to end
up in each other's apartments they do
not think about it before going to sleep
in the morning ming wakes up because of
a slap to his face goo's room has merged
with his and turned into one single
giant room initially they panic and
think they are being burglarized but
then they register the condition of
their rooms which makes them even more
confused outside goo's window is bright
sunny weather while ming's side is
pouring the two stand in front of their
door which is also merged mingos first
and opens his side of the door outside
is a world that seems normal to him but
shocking to goo it turns out he is 25
years old and lives in the year
1999. goo quickly goes through her side
of the door and this time ming is
surprised to see the developed world of
2018 it turns out that they live in the
same apartment but in two different
timelines that have somehow merged into
one goo slaps ming in the face to see if
she is dreaming when it hurts him it is
clear to both of them that their fates
have been tangled with no possible
explanation they try opening the doors
at the same time which causes the
apartment to merge further upon further
inspection they find out they cannot
open each other's door and can only walk
through it when the other person does
goo realizes that in ming's timeline her
father is still alive she quickly makes
her way to her childhood home and sees
her younger self playing with her father
the sight makes her emotional but when
she tries to approach them the earth
shakes and stops her at home ming also
wants to see what happens to him in the
future instead of going out goo gives
him her laptop so he can look himself up
on social media ming is amazed by the
new technology but when he goes to type
his name the ground shakes again they
register that they cannot make contact
with their future or past selves since
two of the same person cannot exist at
the same time at night goo plays music
on the phone and orders food through ai
assistance ming is stunned by everything
that the new phones can do in the
following scene a group of wealthy
businessmen and scientists are in a
meeting about dimensional shifts the
scientist gives an example of a
disappearing plane to prove that it
traveled through time and dimension
before returning to its place of origin
according to his research a merge of the
dimensions has already formed in the
city now all they have to do is find the
coordinates to the place the businessman
plans to use the dimensional portal to
make money we do not see his face
throughout the meeting but it is clear
that he is funding the research to
profit using the phenomenon at night goo
and ming cannot fall asleep goo talks
about her father's death and the impact
it had on her she only has his key ring
to remember him with after the house and
all of his belongings were taken away by
loan sharks the following day they go
about their normal life through the
respective sides of their doors goo is
looking for a rich husband who can buy
her the house in exchange for her hand
in marriage she goes on several dates
with guys but hasn't found anyone who is
willing to fulfill her gold digger
fantasies yet she is on yet another
blind date with a man who seems to like
her very much when he asks her what she
expects in a relationship she shows him
a virtual presentation of the house the
guy feels like he's in a meeting with a
realtor which is definitely not what
he's looking for on a first date then
goo meets a man from an online dating
app she tells him her condition for
marriage and he happily agrees to it it
turns out the man owns a farming
business and is a millionaire he has
double goo's age and talks like a
pervert but she still decides to give
him a chance he wants to pay only half
of the down payment for the house so it
could be bought in both of their names
they go to an atm to withdraw the money
goo goes first and hands the money to
the guy before sending him to buy a
bottle of water but to her unfortunate
luck he turns out to be a scammer who
runs away with her money she has to stay
outside the bank for hours before the
police arrive and investigate ming on
the other hand is enjoying a snack
inside a bathroom stall he overhears the
ceo of his company and his manager
talking about an upcoming business after
the ceo leaves the manager zhao reveals
he plans to steal all of the ceo's money
and make him go bankrupt a few seconds
later he realizes someone is listening
to their conversation and pulls ming out
from the bottom of the stall to keep him
mute zhao offers to loan him the money
that he desperately needs for his
business ming asks for some time to
think about it later that day ming goes
to manager zhao who wants to fire him he
has realized that ming has no evidence
to prove that zhao is planning to betray
the ceo still instead of begging for
himself ming is just worried about the
ceo going bankrupt zhao calls him a
loser for thinking of others above
himself the next day goo is at her work
at the jewelry store when she bumps into
her childhood best friend xiaoya she
pretends to be a rich customer to seem
more appealing to xiaoya who is married
to a millionaire the girls talk for a
while and throughout the conversation
goo boasts about her non-existent
billionaire husband the lies backfire
when xiaoya arranges a dinner between
the two couples for that evening goo
makes ming wear a rented suit and brings
him to the dinner it goes well for the
first half before ming drinks from the
ice cup shows the rent tag in his coat
and says that he works as a ufo
researcher at the end of the night the
fake million dollar diamond and goose
finger falls on the stove and melts she
returns home crying while ming consoles
her the two watched the tv together when
a show about lottery tickets catches
their attention the next day they
excitedly collect the winning numbers of
the lottery ticket and buy them in the
year 1999. even before the results are
announced they start to celebrate goo
takes ming out on a date where they play
vr games walk around the city and go to
the bar at the end of the day they
forget that they are broke and drink
more than they can afford goo promises
the restaurant her expensive purse
promising to return the money the next
day the next morning they wake up on the
same bed they are nervous because it is
the day lottery results will be
announced they eagerly wait for the
announcement and are overjoyed when they
actually win the lottery however it
doesn't last long since the number on
their card disappears right after only
then did the couple realize that they
cannot alter the future in any way but
if so they are confused why their fates
were intertwined goon never gets her bag
back from the restaurant and returns
home angry on the way the duo argues and
calls each other names all of a sudden
they notice ming's face on a large
billboard it is then revealed that in
2018 he changed his name to xi yi and
has become one of the biggest builders
in china he owns a multi-million dollar
company and is about to hold a press
conference in a venue that is only
minutes away ming is shocked to be
looking at his future goo who was
arguing with him a second ago starts
sweet talking him ming goes to the
conference and sees his future self she
ye for the first time but the incident
causes an earthquake and the conference
has to be cancelled she ye realizes what
is going on when a bunch of memories are
added to his brain ming's arm is hurt
which creates a scar on xi yi's arm as
well this means anything ming does will
directly affect xi yi in the future it
is then revealed that the businessman
who wanted to profit off the dimensional
portal is none other than xi yi himself
the scientist says that ming must go
back to how he was before he met gu
because the new memories might affect
his persona which will affect xi yi the
next day min goes to zhao with a
resignation letter since he is bound to
become successful in the future he
doesn't want to accept the money from
zhao the same day xi yi visits goo at
work and takes her out on a date he
claims that he wants to treat her
because he knows she was close to him in
his younger years the man and ming are
the same people but goo doesn't feel
comfortable around xi yi as she feels
with ming he takes her to a fancy
restaurant but it is too awkward for goo
to enjoy at the end of the date xi yi
asks her to stay away from ming because
her involvement will cause him to divert
from his true purpose in life he
promises to buy her the house she always
wanted in turn for her loyalty goo
agrees to do as told not for the house
but for ming's future she returns home
at night and hugs ming before telling
him that she is moving out she also says
that xi yi asked him to take manager
zhao's offer the next day goo moves out
of the apartment but coincidentally her
door is left open by an umbrella this
means maine can go to 2018 even without
her help somewhere else the ceo finds
zhao in his office and finds out about
his plan to betray him zhao panics and
knocks him out before making him gulp
alcohol he plans to kill the man and
make it seem like an accident goo is in
her home after years when she ye arrives
with the bag that she had to give to the
restaurant when xi yi turns around goo
notices a rental tag on his clothes and
realizes it is actually mang she kisses
him and tells him a proper goodbye
before he walks away both of them cry
knowing that they can never meet each
other again when ming reaches home he
gets a call from zhao who calls him on a
bridge he wants to use ming's help to
kill the ceo and make it seem like an
accident ming obviously refuses to do so
but zhao claims that he is in too deep
into the matter to turn away at this
point suddenly ming realizes xi yi chose
to help zhao in the past which is the
reason for his success he took over the
manager's position after the ceo's death
building his empire on blood with time
he became ruthless to the workers and
cared only about money that is why he is
a completely different person from ming
the universe has given ming a chance to
make the right decision this time
furthermore by the ceo's key ring he
discovers he is goo's father all this
time goo is orphaned because of the
decision xi yi took not wanting to make
the same mistake ming saves the man's
life as soon as he does so the evil xi
yi of 2018 disappears meaning ming
changed the future now goo will never
have to lose her father and will grow up
to be someone else this also means that
the current goo will cease to exist in
the final scene we see goo and ming
return to their apartment in different
timelines when they meet in the middle
goo
disappears
well that just goes to show you gold
digging doesn't pay subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching